can two amateur home cooks beat one
professional chef in a cooking
competition
[Music]
what's up everybody I'm Nick from
MasterChef season 10
I've been cooking since I was about
eight or nine years old watching my
grandmother my great grandmother and I
always just loved it
hey guys I'm Spencer I work at BuzzFeed
I'm a home cook and I won the very first
amateur for his professional chef
cooking competition
hi I'm Kayla I work at BuzzFeed I am a
sometimes cook and I won the second
amateur versus professional chef cooking
competition and today we are taking on a
professional chef together we're teaming
up we're gonna take him down we're gonna
try - how's it going we're ready to beat
you so I just ahead don't know what the
challenge is all I know is we're cooking
together against you tell us what the
challenges feeling great about that you
look nervous well I just always look
nervous I eat takeout all the time so I
feel like I'm there we go the two of us
together this is just our challenge I
don't eat takeout oh I wish you good
luck but I don't want you to win great
that's a lot you're goin down fite
alright so walking over I see my two
options it's fast food or the poke a
bowl and right away I'm thinking okay
bull I love fresh fish and I love rice
so I think I can make something pretty
wacky out of this there's a lot of weird
assorted stuff in the fridge from white
chocolate and dark chocolate chips all
the way to eggs and different cheese so
there's a lot of different things I
could work with here I'm gonna get some
oil to fry yeah that's good I think I'm
gonna try to make a sushi burger I'm
gonna break these down into their
different parts so I'll have the rice
and all the fish I'm gonna try out all
these sauces cuz it's good to give them
the try just to see what they are see if
they could add any different dimensions
to the dish because this is a
competition where we have to think
outside the box I want to make something
that's gonna leave them questioning what
they're looking at but also hopefully
give them something that
I think I may try to take that rice and
see if I can work with it on maybe
frying it off to make a bun I'm not sure
how that's gonna work so we'll see what
happens okay what are you thinking we
walk over to the table and I see a
burger and fries and a shake and I have
no idea what to make that's already a
meal in itself how do we elevate that
what do we do to that I thought my
anxiety was out of ten beforehand and
now it's at a 15
it's just through the roof part of me
wants to go a desert route because it's
unexpected and then we can use this I
love a ground beef desert I hate you see
what we have I opened up the fridge and
I see bacon tomatoes chocolate chips
cheese butter basic fridge stuff I
suppose still I had no idea what to do
with any of that
check the cabinet Spencer oh condensed
milk I see this can of condensed milk
and I'm still thinking about the vanilla
milkshake and all the chocolate chips
are in the fridge Rachael Ray has this
awesome 5 minute 5 recipe that I
remembered from my childhood because my
mom and I used to make it together it's
so simple literally just chocolate chips
and condensed milk and I know you love
bacon and youth bacon in your you know
last time so we could use some of that
and I was thinking okay well we have to
use the French fries that would be like
the salty component with the bacon and
the vanilla shake could be like vibe
together they definitely do like the
salty sweet lemonade I was here for it
sounds like a sweet route I hate you so
much
I have to be a little bit wary of the
fact that they both separately won their
competitions before in this so they're
both winners and they're teaming up here
I have some competition to face so you
guys oh yeah yeah okay so the clock
countdown three two one and the first
thing that happened this isn't actually
food the trash-talking you already
starts so it seems like it's gonna be
more of a trash talking back and forth
an actual cooking showdown making the
bacon
I bet nick has never made bacon in his
life I've made a lot of bacon yeah that
sounds fake he's a professional chef and
I don't want to lose this game so I
think we have to like throw some shada
and we have to trash-talk them we have
to you have to be a little mean I can't
be my used to competition hey Nick do
you need oil for bacon like I know bacon
has a lot of fat no you don't you guys
can ask one more question I'm not
helping you after that I gave them one
last question that I would answer to
help them through competition and their
question was how is it gonna feel to
lose the two amateurs it's not your
question they wasted it and that's
totally fine I'm just gonna toast my
sesame seeds over here and mind my own
business you know okay
well good luck with your little sesame
seeds I'm really good at cooking bacon
let's just test it mmm love that sizzle
they're cooking their bacon doesn't look
like the pans hot enough either no don't
listen to him don't love them like you
have you've won with this wig I don't
worry about I definitely wouldn't turn
up the heat on the bacon
I'm tossing all these different tips at
them about their pan and the heat of it
for cooking their bacon and I think I'm
getting in their heads a little bit
how's your bacon looking over there it's
like
I'll be the best bacon I've ever cooked
ever you want me teach you a trick over
here yeah
one hand egg cracked come on you do that
ever oh yeah all the time like all in my
spare time before I go to bed like that
and then with one hand no I've never
made bacon before you haven't made bacon
before I don't eat bacon too late to
switch teams
Keller wanted to switch teams all of us
on master Shi trash-talking me above so
it was too late for that
how are you gonna taste your food I mean
I seen it eat it
have you guys just only touched the
bacon so far well we only have one thing
but also the fudge
we need the bacon to be done to
incorporate was gonna see if I could get
one off the tray in expand from here it
was trying to throw chocolate chips into
my frying oil which would have probably
ruined it I'm just letting them do their
thing and they can get distracted all
they want and if it gets in you have to
keep it there I don't be better than and
you missed my burning the bacon was
burning while we were doing that so
really it was a distraction on ourselves
and we owned ourselves self sever yeah
[Music]
we would like flowering over there
she was like pat pat flower flower I was
like I'm actually a little worried about
the rice holding together with my funds
for my sushi burger but I love trying
new things and kind of just going for it
so if this doesn't work I'll figure it
out
brutal Ray's recipe calls for a mixture
of regular summer are you guys involve h
'l raised recipe to wrestle raise the
queen of 30-minute meals I don't need
this trash-talking my favorite Food
Network Star is over the whole point is
to make your own dish the key to winning
this is gonna be started figuring out
your own thing to do with this and
they're over there focusing on Rachael
Ray's her recipe so I don't know what's
gonna happen with them and we're adding
bacon and french fries to it Rachael Ray
did this I'm you know what a great chef
steals from other people that's not true
[Laughter]
[Music]
Feli coat the fries in the leftover
frying their fries and the bacon fat a
little bit that's clever that's
professional chef stuff
my buns are in but I don't know what's
gonna happen when they come out so
they're gonna burn it's a big waiting
game what are we doing
oh you're Kayla ran over to my station
and was trying to mess me up a little
bit these are my buns over there Oh God
everybody oh my gosh
not that bad right no what if we just
made the best dessert in the world
honestly I would take full credit I did
the can in a plastic wrap just because
then we can take it off and I'll easily
slide off like it's not cooked Nick
comes over leaves his station unattended
and I'm like mwah ha ha ha now it's my
time to give the ultimate distraction
ooh I have a game while we wait you guys
just stay over there and I'm gonna try
to get em in your mouth let's take this
back to elementary school let's see if I
can toss two chocolate chips in your
mouth killed at least two and a half
minutes who knows what was happening to
his food with patties are gonna burn
that was great sabotaging and I think
that he burned his stuff so I don't
think I'm gonna take it easy on these
two just because they're so confident in
their abilities right now and I have to
really just drive at home I'm gonna give
it all I've got nice all of a sudden but
really I think we need to get the judges
in here because that's that's the way
we'll really find out who won word let's
do it let's go it's warm I'm seeing some
seeds here at the top I'm gonna go ahead
and dive right in so good on the money
it does look like a lot of cooking
techniques and hard work was put into
this but I am NOT a fan I would
definitely eat like three of these I
don't know if I'm allowed to eat all the
advice if I'm gonna be totally honest
this kind of looks a little bit like a
poop letter not looking too great mmm
okay here we go
somehow this is worse I see what they
were going for very sweet I'm not mad
about it I'm really not mad about this
sweet and salty is definitely a popular
combo the french fries and bacon a
little off-putting
but hey we do what we can I would have
to say dish number one is my favorite
I'll definitely have to go with this
option I'm definitely gonna go for the
first dish I tried I thought the buns
are really innovative I love rice rice
is my life all the ingredients
complement each other well the seeds
that he put on top added a little bit of
extra crunch on top of the already crisp
that you get from the rice paddy I can't
say enough about this thing clear winner
right here in this competition of
amateur chefs versus professional chef
sue cow challenge the winner is can I
have a drum roll please
oh it's obviously him it's very clear
that you are a master chef and we're the
amateurs two heads are not better than
one we couldn't do it but that's great
for you well done thank you I'm just
gonna go cry I'll have to battle against
ya know we'll do this again and we won't
have to cook using fast food next time
[Music]